[Musique]
bienvenue au sur france 3 bourgogne
merci d'être avec nous édition spéciale
ce soir en direct depuis le morvan pour
évoquer la problématique des commerces
dans les milieux rural un restaurant
boulangerie bistrot difficile d'enrayer
la valse des fermetures nous verrons
qu'il est parfois compliqué de trouver
un repreneur
exemple en côte d'or d'autant plus
difficile que les petits commerces
doivent faire face à la concurrence des
supermarchés et des nouveaux modes de
consommation
1 nous irons voir comment ça se passe
dans la nièvre et pour parler de ce
sujet on s'est installé à
quarré-les-tombes un village où les
commerces eux résistent vous allez voir
nous tenterons de comprendre pourquoi
avec nos invités dans un instant voilà
pour le sommaire bonsoir à tous nous
sommes donc à à quarré-les-tombes sur la
place du village quarré-les-tombes 700
habitants 13 commerces toujours en
activité un vrai moteur pour l'économie
et voyez le reportage de sébastien kérou
et claude
corinne est ce que l'on appelle une
résistante son salon de coiffure est
devenu une institution à
quarré-les-tombes voilà maintenant vingt
ans qu'elle travaille dans ce petit
village du morvan et depuis les clients
sont toujours rendez vous l'activité est
plus calme du zoo en hiver et autrement
six mois de l'année avec les maisons
secondaires ça bouge énormément
les commerçants zones rurales car elle
est tombée fait figure d'exception
quatre restaurants une pharmacie une
supérette de boucher et même une station
service
tout ça pour seulement 700 habitants et
ce n'est pas simone et odette qui vont
s'en plaindre
les deux retraités ont leurs petites
habitudes on trouve tout un carré c'est
quand même très important à west wing
chance parce que tout autour ya des
petits ménages mais y'a rien du tout
alors quand on vieillit c'est pas drôle
un des secrets de cette vitalité des
commerçants déterminés à sauver leur
village quand un commerce ferme
il faut rapidement le rouvrir c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait sébastien il
vient de racheter ce fonds de commerce
le bar avait fermé il ya à peu près au
mois de novembre
nous on a décidé de le racheter on
refait des travaux on a encore un peu
près trois semaines de travaux on
devrait pouvoir leur ouvrir au 15 avril
normalement avec ce nouvel établissement
sébastien possédera désormais deux
barres sur quarré les tombes de quoi
accueillir plus de clients le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que si tu as des
commerces qui ferment en fin de compte
le village commencent à mourir commence
toujours par les écoles ensuite le café
la boulangerie et à la fin il n'y a plus
rien un petit village aux portes du
morvan qui résiste encore et toujours à
la désertification les commerçants de
quarré-les-tombes n'attendent plus
qu'une seule chose le retour de l'été et
son cortège de touristes voilà et nous
sommes rentrés dans l'une des boutiques
de ce village c'est jérôme marchand le
boulanger chocolatier de la commune pour
soir jérôme bonsoir merci de nous
accueillir chez vous qu'est ce qui fait
le succès de ce village d'après vous
aussi historique car il tombe sur une
place forte du commerce et de
l'artisanat
13 commerces 21 artisans donc un tissu
associatif très très fort qu'a toujours
fait la promotion du des commerçants et
artisans avec des foires artisanales
aussi chaque année voilà est aussi une
plateforme de santé complète du
pharmacien jusqu'aux médecins
donc on a tous les services de proximité
qui sont réunis à quarré-les-tombes mois
est-ce que vous avez hésité vous au
moment de reprendre c'était en 2005
alors on aurait pu se positionner sur
une création où une reprise on avait
préféré le choix de la reprise on était
sûr sur une reprise pas sur un tissu
patriarche héritiers ou la transmission
s'est pas fait
nous on s'est retrouvé comme eu comme
entrepreneur ce qui nous a permis de
conserver sept postes salariés dans
l'entreprise des gens qui possèdent et
qui étaient diplômés compétents et qui
possédait le savoir faire ce qui
permettait aussi de son bon coeur tout à
fait voilà aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ses dix salariés avec tout
un travail aussi exogènes le territoire
parce qu'on dépasse aussi les portes du
morvan pour maintenir aussi cette
activité l'hiver merci où on vous
retrouve dans un instant parler de
quarré-les-tombes à un village qui fait
figure d'exception depuis dix ans dans
notre région 150 commerces ont fermé
leurs portes en notre région l'état des
lieux tout de suite avec sébastien
leuthard ces dernières années des
dizaines de commerces bourguignons ont
définitivement baissé le rideau
concernant les boulangeries pâtisseries
et les boucheries charcuteries depuis
2010 150 boutiques ont mis la clé sous
la porte soit une baisse de 9%
mais le phénomène est inégalement
répartie en côte d'or le nombre de
commerces de bouche a légèrement
augmenté de 1% ces neuf dernières années
mais en saône et loire les chiffres sont
à la baisse -1 9% depuis 2010 baisse
aussi dans l'yonne
enfin dans la nièvre le recul atteint
les 24 % en seulement huit ans un
exemple on comptait 186 boulangerie
pâtisserie nivernaise en 2010
depuis une quarantaine ont baissé le
rideau faut-il y voir un lien en
bourgogne c'est la nièvre qui compte la
plus grande densité de supermarchés avec
en moyenne plus de 13 grandes surfaces
pour cent mille habitants
voilà et ses commerces qui ferment ce
sont souvent des commerçants qui partent
à la retraite et qui ne parviennent pas
à trouver de repreneur tout de suit
l'exemple de nos les échos repos c'est
avec fabienne acosta et remis aux échecs
pour les images à vendre cause retraite
la fiche n'est peut être pas assez
grosse mais à corpeau 18 mille véhicules
passent devant ce panneau chaque jour et
rien n'y fait aline et son mari n'ont
jamais trouvé de repreneur potentiel
seule une visite en quatre ans corpo est
quand même porteur il y a quand même les
métiers de la vigne et tout ça qu'ils
sont quand même porteur chassagne tout
ça sont à proximité chagny c'est quand
même important c'est quand même un
croisement important je ne sais pas ce
qui bloque le pont de paris
c'est pourtant l'un des plus anciens
restaurants de la nationale 6 et sa
réputation n'est plus à faire
c'est complet chaque midi le couple a
contacté une agence immobilière il y a
deux ans il continue d'espérer un rachat
plutôt que d'envisager une fermeture
définitive
on va jusqu'à ce qu'on puisse puisse
plus le problème est là mais je pense
qu'un jour on va
on va pas tomber mais on va embêter on
va être épuisé on a l'impression qu'on
va remettre obligé de fermer sans
transmettre
je suis très fort et c'est à nolay
quelques kilomètres plus loin
l' angoisse des commerçants est aussi un
sentiment ambiant
ici presque un commerce sur deux est à
vendre comme ce tabac pourtant très
rentable
la mairie ne se serait jamais impliqué
pour lui trouver un repreneur
christelle la gérante et passer par des
agences immobilières
cela fait deux ans qu'elle attend j'ai
eu un ou deux appels
et quand j'ai dit que c'était à nolay a
priori les personnes n'étaient pas trop
intéressé et puis des visites jamais ok
c'est pas le prix qui bloque donc ya pas
alors entre dire que c'est calme en ce
moment
voilà voilà ce qui ressort le plus
souvent c'est pas la bonne période
ça fait deux ans que c'est par la
volonté riad à nolay corpo ces villages
ruraux savent pourtant attirer la
clientèle mais pas les repreneurs
difficulté d'obtenir des prêts bancaires
ou peur de la masse de travail
deux explications possibles les agences
compte en moyenne trois ans pour vendre
les fonds de commerce
voilà on se retrouve à nouveau à la
chocolaterie de jérôme marchand jérôme
être commerçant la campagne est ce que
c'est un métier difficile et de labeur
c'est un métier très laborieux voilà
c'est c'est beaucoup d'heures par
semaine
il ya beaucoup de corporations et aussi
on est sur des terres d'élevage
il ya beaucoup aussi de gens qui font
beaucoup d'heures et c'est le prix à
payer c'est je pense que c'est tout à
fait normal d'avoir un résultat par
rapport au nombre d'heures qu'ils sont
fait un bout c'est venu comment dès le
ce2 voilà c'est dit ouais tout petit je
voulais faire ce métier-là des ce2 voilà
on allait le matin on allait au caté
l'après midi on allait au centre social
et ça a démarré par un gâteau au yaourt
voilà mais aujourd'hui des chocolats
tout à fait s'installer jérôme à la
campagne quand on a 30 ans en couple
tenir une boutique est ce que c'est pas
quelque chose qui est qui est passée de
mode aujourd'hui
non parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
on a des jeunes ruraux sur le territoire
qui restent sur le territoire qui est
qui ont travaillé aussi dons qui vont
rêver précocément sur le le le au niveau
du du travail dans nos entreprises
ensuite on a des jeunes qui vont partir
à la ville se qualifier et c'est cela
qui sont le plus dur a touché pour
revenir travailler sur le territoire
euros donc on a des difficultés
notamment à recruter alors justement
puisque vous parlez de recrutement on va
s'intéresser à la reprise d'un commerce
c'est une étape souvent délicate je vous
propose d'écouter les solutions
proposées par la chambre des métiers de
l'artisanat de l'yonne en écoute
comment faciliter la reprise de
commerces on facilite la reprise
d'entreprises déjà en mettant en
relation les repreneurs d'entreprise et
les dirigeants d'entreprise qui souhaite
céder et qui recherche quelqu'un pour
pour leur succéder
donc ça c'est la première étape ensuite
on facilite ma part la formation des
repreneurs d'entreprise et la promotion
des métiers de l'artisanat auprès du
grand public
quel accompagnement pour les repreneurs
il ya un nouvel accompagnement qui
s'appelle pro forêt art qui est financé
par le conseil régional de bourgogne
franche comté ce qui permet gratuitement
pour un repreneur d'entreprise d'aller
passer un stage dans l'entreprise qu'il
envisage de reprendre et bénéficier de
toute une offre de formation à la carte
pourquoi ces métier n'attire plus c'est
vrai qu'on entend souvent parler dans
l'artisanat de difficultés liées à la
gestion de l'entreprise de poids des
charges c'est des difficultés qui sont
réels mais ça reste malgré tout des
métiers qui attire beaucoup de monde on
le voit nous en accueillant toutes les
semaines de très nombreux porteurs de
projets qui veulent créer ou reprendre
une entreprise
voilà donc de retour sur cette place du
village de quarré-les-tombes pour
évoquer la problématique des commerces à
la campagne à mes côtés maintenant
sylvie soyez vous êtes première adjointe
au maire du village
sylvie quelle solution que ton mettre en
place à l'échelle de la commune pour
attirer pour favoriser le commerce alors
la commune s'est toujours attaché à
développer des infrastructures qui font
venir du monde
nous avons un gymnase nous avons une
très belle salle polyvalente nous avons
une aire de camping-car
nous accueillons la maison de services
et au public à l'intérieur de la mairie
et nous misons beaucoup sur le tourisme
sûr que ce soit le tourisme en randonnée
aussi en vtt
je crois que vous avez aussi lutte pour
garder une station service saas est
important c'est pas tout à fait ça la
dernière station service à fermer en
2012 et nous nous sommes trouvés bien
dépourvu par s'il n'y avait plus cet
élément essentiel à mon sens dans une
économie qui marche et donc nous avons
étudiées des solutions avec des
entrepreneurs locaux et nous avons enfin
réussi à faire un partenariat avec un
artisan qui n'est pas très loin d'ici et
qui a monté cette station service 24/24
et c est une réelle opportunité pour les
habitants de carrés et pour toutes les
personnes agressées de logements pour
les pour les jeunes les futurs
commerçants ça c'est important
voilà au niveau de la région nous sommes
répertorié comme pôle de proximité dans
son schéma régional de développement et
d'aménagement du territoire
nous avons bien conscience qu'il y à 46
entreprises sur le territoire de la
commune que ces entreprises ont besoin
de main d'oeuvre qu'il faut qu'elles
forment des apprentis pour bien sûr
espérer les garder en tant qu'ouvrier et
reprend de leur commerce mais le
problème c'est que ces apprentis n'ont
souvent pas de moyen de locomotion et
non pas un salaire suffisant pour s'il
fallait un à loyer un lieu pour les
hébergeurs voile en question celui
est-ce que vous avez un supermarché
dessus il n'y a pas de supermarché à
quarré-les-tombes alors les supermarchés
sont souvent pointées du
on va en parler avec vous dans un
instant ce sont pourtant parfois de
véritables pôles d'attractivité on va
partir à sombernon près de dijon
vous allez voir là bas il y a deux
moyennes surfaces et la cohabitation
avec les petits commerces et bien le se
passe très bien
sylvain billau lucie martin sombernon
950 habitants est tout de même deux
supermarchés
le plus ancien s'est installé à la fin
des années 80 l'autre il ya tout juste
dix ans apparemment tous deux ont trouvé
leur clientèle
bah c'est bien je trouve parce qu'il
faut un peu concluant ce que j'apprécie
c'est qu'ils font travailler le tissu
local et que la qualité quand même
supérieurs à la moyenne des grandes
surfaces base est très utile oui puis
maintenant on a beaucoup de choses de
plus en plus avant c'était pas autant
sur son perron maintenant à fury sont à
médecins mal super hulne est haut au
dessus on apprend plein de choses donc
c'est mieux
et effectivement ici le petit commerce
fait bien plus que résister un
tabac-presse de boulangerie de salon de
coiffure une agence immobilière
au total une vingtaine de boutiques et
la dernière en date une boucherie
rebouché soutenu par la mairie le
boucher ouvert sa boutique il y un an
il emploie aujourd'hui quatre salariés
cette réussite n'étonne pas monsieur le
maire les grandes surfaces comme les
petits commerces tourne bien et c'est ça
l'important va fermer les commerces et
si c'est pour qu'un an après mais
d'après lui apporta probable lors que là
je fais pas les comptes avec eux mais je
pense que vu de l'extérieur ça
fonctionne bien je vais pas tirer les
prix comme les grandes supermarché mais
par contre est alors que moi derrière je
mette de la bonne qualité quoi donc
c'est complètement différent
je pense que voilà c'est là la
différence est là il faut qu'il y en ait
pour tous la complémentarité de l'offre
la clé de la coexistence entre
supermarchés et petits commerces en
milieu rural pas seulement la zone de
chalandise semble être un facteur
déterminant
notre situation géographique qu'on fait
qu'on soit un pôle d'attractivité et
donc tous et tous les villages alentour
qui viennent ici parce qu'évidemment
mille habitants ce ne serait pas
suffisant pour alimenter un délai
commerce et autant de commerces comme on
les a vecteur d'attractivité mais aussi
de financement pour les communes rurales
à sombernon les deux supermarchés
représente 40 mille euros de taxes voilà
pour l'exemple de son père dont près de
dijon 1 sylvie soyez ce qu'un
supermarché vous l'envisagez vous ici à
quarré-les-tombes un supermarché n'est
pas envisagée à quarré les tombes et
jeunes à ma connaissance ça n'a jamais
été envisagé pour quelles raisons alors
pour quelle raison un supermarché
correspond à un aménagement du
territoire donc la commune de carey ne
peut pas être seul à décider
ce supermarché ne pourrait pas être au
coeur du village
qu'est-ce que rennes demande des
habitants donc il faudrait qu'il y ait
une concertation très forte pour avoir
l'adhésion de la population et
l'adhésion des 13 commerces qui sont
autour de la place parce que cette place
constitue véritablement le coeur du
village et c'est pour ça que le commerce
marche à cary pour l'instant ce n'est
pas d'actualité merci aux années madame
sylvie soyez d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir si on l'a vu on l'a entendu les
supermarchés peuvent être vues parfois
comme une concurrence directe pour les
petits commerces tout comme les
nouvelles pratiques de consommation sur
internet ou avec les drives on va voir
comment ça se passe à saint-éloi dans la
nièvre c'est avec rémy chidaine et tanya
gomez récupérer ces courses sont passés
par les rayons simple et rapide en
sortant du travail parfois aussi une
solution à l'absence de commerces comme
pour cette dame qui habite un village à
10 km il y avait une petite épicerie
mais malheureusement qui a fermé voilà
non non non c'est le vert après la plus
proche on sait quelque chose qui est
très pratique pour moi de pouvoir fermer
et mes courses en drive c'est plus
pratique on a réuni vie il cherche
directement dans le coffre et on rentre
à la maison c'est beaucoup plus simple
que d'aller dans les magasins où on
passe beaucoup plus de temps pour les
clients c'est un moyen de compléter le
petit commerce mais pas forcément de le
remplacer le commerce de proximité très
intéressant aussi parce qu'il ya le
contact et puis c'était très important
et puis le commerce comme ça avec en
drive à permet aux personnes de prendre
des courses plus rapidement enfin mardi
les deux modes sont très intéressants
résultat ce dry peut créer en 2012
représente aujourd'hui entre 5 et 10% du
chiffre d'affaires de l'hypermarché à
nevers
c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne bien
qui se développe qui prend des parts de
marché d'année en année on a des
progressions assez assez intéressante
sur ce modèle mais quand prendre sa
voiture n'est pas possible c'est le
supermarché qui peut venir jusqu'à vous
chaque jour sébastien poirier emmène son
camion épicerie sur les routes
un arrêt par client et pour certains
c'est l'occasion de prendre le
nécessaire pour la semaine
ap de tous que ce soit les légumes la
viande
pas du tout tout ce qu il a quoi
heureusement qu'ils passent en congé
nous donnons campagne cette société
possède six camions et dessert la nièvre
mais aussi l'yonne le loiret et le cher
un lien essentiel particulièrement pour
les clients âgés face à la
désertification des zones rurales très
important déjà pour pour le bien-être
des gens déjà les personnes seules qui
sont beaucoup seul donc ça leur rapporte
un petit réconfort un petit petite
visite en fait on va dire drive ou
supermarchés itinérant dans tous les cas
un commerce qui nécessitent un
déplacement
une évolution devenu obligatoire faute
de pouvoir s'approvisionner au plus près
voilà est de retour à quarré les tombes
où j'ai changé de boutiers camps se
trouvent maintenant chez le caviste du
village jean françois galland bonsoir à
vous accueillir
on vient de parler de la concurrence des
supermarchés des drive est ce que ça
vous fait peur vous cette concurrence là
oui et non plutôt non plutôt non parce
que je pense que quand on a la
connaissance de ses producteurs de ces
vignerons de ses artisans
on arrive à en parler alors évidemment
on n'a peut-être pas les mêmes volumes
de ventes que la grande distribution
mais je crois que les gens sont pas la
recherche un petit peu d'autres choses
aujourd'hui
alors vous vous étiez libraire apparaît
vous avez tout quitté pour venir ouvrir
une boutique ici on trouve du vin on
trouve de la décoder des produits du
terroir qu'est ce qui vous est pris une
idée un peu folle
un matin se dire tiens et si j'habitais
dans le village où j'ai passé toutes mes
vacances alors par enfant mais c'est
déjà un choix d'adulte d'acquérir une
résidence secondaire puis voilà puis les
enfants grandissent en étant un petit
peu plus hors d'eau bal avec mon épouse
on s'est lancés on dit allez faisons le
sans savoir ce qu'on allait réellement
faire d'ailleurs au début alors votre
crédo c'est du 100% local et puis alors
surtout beaucoup beaucoup des changes
100% local et dévoila des histoires
maintenant on n'est pas là pour
évidemment qu'on est là pour vendre je
vais pas dire que je suis un
philanthrope
mais on est surtout là pour partager
raconter des histoires et voilà et
ramener des vignes des ateliers des
fermes des choses réelles
c'est déjà un geste de venir chez vous
achetez quelque chose je pense ouais
ouais mais les gens s'y trompe pas
d'ailleurs que ce soit les gens du
village où les gens de passage
il voit tout de suite que bach c'est
voilà c'est un endroit où on cause c'est
un endroit où on va prendre le temps et
puis on va parler d'eux surtout de notre
région qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici à
quarré-les-tombes n'ya pas ailleurs
la place est clairement la place bah je
vais pas vous avez vu c'est vraiment une
espèce de croisement de route jeu pour
vous refaire toute l'histoire
mais quiconque arrive aujourd'hui pour
aller voir les lacs pour aller faire du
vélo pour se reposer on est bloqué par
cette place qui a une forme incroyable
dans l'histoire de la ruralité française
des belles places comme ça un peu
triangulaire où on s'arrête
moi j'en connais peu merci jean françois
mais je vous en prie allez pour terminer
cette édition je vais retrouver c'était
anneux paris rédacteur en chef de france
bleu auxerre stephan vous avez est
étonné de ce que vous avez entendu là
depuis le début de l'émission
non je vais dire que cette problématique
du commerce rural on leur trouve un peu
partout sur tous les territoires les
jolystes de france glossaire qui
sillonnent tous les jours le territoire
remarque malheureusement que dans les
villages les commerces ferment alors
plutôt que de s'appesantir sur la
fermeture des commerces
nous on préfère signaler les endroits où
des commerces ouvrent et dernièrement à
ancy le franc dans le tonnerrois et bien
si commerces ont ouvert en cinq ans il
ya trente cinq commerces dans cette dans
cette commune pour montrer que
finalement c'est pas une fatalité qui a
une volonté il peut y avoir une volonté
des commerçants des élus comme vous
l'avez montré ce soir ici à quarré les
tombes de pousser les petits commerces
et de maintenir de la vie donc dans les
territoires il ya une demande de plus de
proximité dans les commerces mais aussi
dans les médias à la radio à la
télévision
oui j'allais dire que france bleu france
bleu auxerre et la radio de la proximité
je le disais les reporters sont tous les
jours en contact avec avec les gens
proches proche des gens et dans les
préoccupations quotidiennes des des gens
c'est de savoir est-ce que dura un
commerce est ce que le boulanger va
ouvrir aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils
pourront faire leurs courses et ce
qu'ils pourront aller mettre de
l'essence prêt auprès du village et
c'est vrai que cette problématique on la
traite régulièrement sur france bleu sur
france bleu auxerre et on est proche on
est proche des gens les proches de cette
problématique et je pense que c'est
important pour défendre de nos
territoires
merci stéphane je précise qu'on va
pouvoir retrouver tous les reportages
sur le site de france bleu et puis bien
sûr sur le site de france 3 bourgogne
merci d'avoir été avec nous
l'information continue très belle soirée
sur france 3
[Musique]